okay okay let's see if this works
it should be going live
we are now live with
mick west this is brian keating
into the impossible podcast we will
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
arthur c clark center for human
imagination or my video
and my motto is abc always be
curious mick how are you today
where are you joining us from doing
great i'm joining you from sacramento
and uh yeah i must say that arthur c
clarke was one of my favorite science
fiction authors when i was growing up
and i also watched him on tv a lot he
had a tv show in britain so
i'm a big arthur c clark fan very good
i am honored to be the co-director of
the arthur c clarke center for human
imagination and arthur
had many many sayings one of which i use
as the title of this podcast which is
the only way of discovering the limits
of the possible is to venture
a little way past them into the
impossible
and another one which will come up today
undoubtedly is
for every expert there's an equal and
opposite expert
and the third one which we open all of
our regularly scheduled interviews with
is that uh any sufficiently advanced
technology
is indistinguishable from magic and
we're going to talk about some magical
technology today perhaps that has been
reported
and i want to talk about some of the
implications of this
technology if it's true if it's if it's
uh
if it did actually exist and and some of
the evidence that we have as a scientist
i'm always
of course interested not so much in
belief but in evidence
and i want to hearken back to that great
uh
hunter of evidence and that is carl
sagan he was not a knight
like like arthur c clarke was but he did
say things such as extraordinary claims
require extraordinary evidence now mick
i'm a scientist
i never reach into a bag that says uh
you know here's the extraordinary
evidence
i don't know about you but first can we
get uh a little quick
recap for listeners in my podcast um can
you give me a quick recap of how you
came to
study uh such phenomena that are
unexplained first of all
sure sure well i'm not a scientist i'm
actually a former video game
programmer which you might think doesn't
suit me well for doing this type of
thing
but it's actually a lot of the the
mathematics that i use in analyzing ufo
videos are the exact same mathematics
that i used
programming video games because you have
to do the same type of
calculations to figure out where things
are in 3d space and how you transform
one to the other
and the very simple physics that you do
in video games
is often all the physics you actually
need to figure out certain things that
are going on in
ufo videos so i kind of got interested
in
ufos maybe about four years ago and
before that i was doing a lot of
investigation into
various conspiracy theories one of which
was the chemtrails conspiracy theory so
i got really interested in
you know tracking down where planes are
in space and things like that and that
just naturally translated
into the the ufo realm and i
started looking at these interesting ufo
videos and trying to figure out what
they were showing
and recently there's been an upsurge in
interest
in all different venues i started to get
interested in this
courtesy of a very good friend of mine
who's uh i call him
you know the atomic clock eric weinstein
because uh
they say a broken clock is right twice a
day but you know eric's been right about
an awful lot of things and it's
it's very hard to dismiss what he is
interested in and so i
i take him very seriously uh from all
sorts of things like
lab leaks of certain things that uh
shall not be named currently
uh to uh to other sorts of things that
might be considered fringe or conspiracy
uh he tends to be right more often than
not and anything that interests him
peaks his interest will certainly pique
my interest and so um
he's sort of more convinced than than
i've seen him in a long time that
there's something here
that there's some uh something to pay
attention to
so that's good enough for me to at least
pay attention to it now i'm a physicist
i'm an experimental physicist he's a
theoretical
he's actually a mathematician by
training but interested in the
theoretical implications
of such technology he's made statements
on clubhouse and elsewhere that
you know he's curious who knows about
these phenomena
who's watching these phenomena we've had
conversations with ryan graves on
clubhouse and um
and on and off who is one of the fighter
pilots who's
been interviewed by 60 minutes maybe
he's watching maybe he's not
uh he's a very generous individual um as
well as alexanditrich
who's shown a great deal of class and
dignity and talking about this
and i believe that these individuals who
have provided eyewitness accounts
are credible they're highly trained
they're incredibly patriotic and
motivated
i don't think there are ill intentions
here
but there's certainly a lot of passion
involved i don't want to talk about the
why people are motivated to do things
but to what do you attribute uh this
most recent upsurge is it this
marco rubio you know instigated report
this pentagon data dump
what is contributing to it and what you
know why now what's the nancy kerrigan
you know kind of background on all this
why why now why me
well i think eric's take really is about
uh whether smoke there's fire
and that's really what he's looking at
he's seeing that there's a lot of talk
about it going on at
relatively high levels you know we've
recently had uh
former president obama talk about it a
couple of times in different situations
and people are
are bringing it up uh i think what we're
seeing is kind of a culmination of
something that's been going on for a
number of years
and you can kind of trace it back to
about four years ago with the
publication
of the new york times article uh titled
uh glowing auras and black money
which kind of revealed the existence of
this uh this pentagon program called
atip which was uh
in in part uh supposedly studying
uaps or ufos and it was also looking
into various types of advanced
technology like you know warp drives
potentially
hypothetical things and different types
of energy sources and whatnot
but you know this story came out and
with that came a couple of videos that
looked like
initially there were really impressive
videos of ufos
and people started looking at these
videos and it got on
the media and that kind of started a
feedback loop that's been going on i
think
for about the last four years really and
what we're seeing now is in some ways
a culmination of that that uh that kind
of media tsunami of
interest fueling the public interest
which fuels more interest and then
politicians get interested in this as
well and it just kind of has been on a
roll
ever since then but i don't you know
saying that i don't think it's just
simply
an issue of the media promoting this and
these people promoting this there's also
very real issues that are going on
that are kind of related to the whole uh
phenomena you know we have a real issue
with
unidentified objects and you know if the
navy can't identify something that's in
their airspace that's a real issue so
it's not like there's
there's nothing going on but i think we
do perhaps have a bit of a
conflation of two things we have all
this media interest which is really
driven by the idea that these might be
aliens
and then we have a bunch of uh real
issues which have to do with like things
like drones and
unidentified airspace incursions but
it's all kind of coming to the head and
i'm kind of hopeful that this
coming report might resolve a few
questions
and that was uh kind of slated at the
end of the trump administration
initiated by marco rubio and others
talked about in a recent interview on 60
minutes a couple weeks
back and that had a six-month fuse about
to expire
in june and that um
you know kind of set the wheels in
motion at least in my mind that
this was sort of interesting although
i've been saying you know this might be
kind of the last opportunity if it turns
out to be nothing and and so
in talking with eric on clubhouse and
elsewhere i've been saying you know
might this not be a case of you know
uh buy the rumor sell the news if folks
are going to get interested about it
uh we might want to capitalize on
attention uh for those that might have
purposes other than the pure
actual uh investigation of scientific
phenomenon
yeah i think a lot of people are
actually uh who are promoting this are
actually already
convinced and they're not really so much
interested in the scientific
investigation
uh of are these amazing phenomena or are
these natural phenomena they're actually
convinced that these are
in many cases they're convinced that
they are aliens you know the way that
they talk about it it's not
human essentially and so you've got kind
of a you know two things there you've
got
people trying to promote the idea that
these are aliens
and then you've got people trying to
figure out what they actually are
now in my field of astronomy we have a
tradition
actually called great debates these go
back hundreds of years actually back to
the
time of copernicus galileo kepler etc
continuing through a hundred years ago
exactly last year what was called the
great debate the size of the universe
the scope of the universe is the milky
way the entirety of the universe
was actually called the great debate
even though it was just one of many
and i actually feel that debate is
almost pointless in science yeah
it's very hard to convince somebody of
of an opinion
especially as upton sinclair said if his
or her job depends on it
not believing a fact to be true but i do
believe that
uh that the perspective of two different
opposing sides can be valuable
at revealing truth and for that reason
i've had on diametrically
opposed forces on the into the
impossible podcast
i've had on michael saylor perhaps the
world's most preeminent
proponent of bitcoin and blockchain
technology and i've had on
his arch nemesis peter schiff uh as well
as other proponents of gold versus
blockchain not at the same time i didn't
have them debate each other i've had on
noam chomsky
and his uh ideological alter ego ben
shapiro
i don't know people that have had on you
know such diametrically opposed forces
i've had on
uh kamran vapha at harvard and i've had
on
uh and michio kaku the foremost
proponents of string theory in the
universe
as i know it and i've had on as i said
eric weinstein sabine hassenfelder
and and many other great opponents of
string theory so i am not unaccustomed
to this and i have
had commitments from some of the pilots
uh who have uh
been involved in some of these tentative
commitments i should say and i don't
want to say which ones
uh to come on the into the impossible
podcast and i am grateful for that uh
not only for their patriotism far beyond
anything i would ever show
but i do want to say that i think it's
it's useful as
i will ask them i want to ask you for
your perspective on their
um on their reports and for uh i'm going
to ask them on their perspective on
your report so some of the reports that
have been made
and on lex friedman's podcast who's a
friend of mine and
and has been very vocal about these
things is it
not possible that because you are not an
expert
in uh and that flir systems and the pods
that are installed on the on the
on the super hornets that were involved
in the 2004 nimitz encounter
uh which was not far from where i am now
in san diego
uh you're not an expert you're not
operating this shouldn't you be
contacting engineers at raytheon to
learn how to use this
uh isn't it possible that you're falling
into the confirmation bias fallacy
that's
really befuddled astronomer scientist
ever since the time of galileo up
through einstein
and beyond sure and i would love to talk
to raytheon and i
tried to contact them a couple of times
and got nothing other people have tried
to contact them on my behalf
and they've said basically well we refer
you to
the users of the equipment for what's
actually going on
uh so you know i would really like to
talk to experts i've had people who
uh say they're experts in the the flea
system which is not really the same
thing exactly but the
uh rebut me but you know essentially
it's you know i kind of disagree with
them because i
think that they're not actually
understanding my argument but it becomes
very problematic
because you know here's me you know a
former video game programmer
who is certainly not someone with much
experience in in these systems and i'm
putting forward theories and hypotheses
and other people who ostensibly have
more experience than me
say that i'm wrong but i think usually
what happens in these situations
is that they're not actually
addressing the arguments that i'm
raising which sounds kind of very
presumptuous on my part i understand how
that how that sounds
but if you look into what we're actually
talking about there's one
one issue in particular that i talk
about quite a bit which is to do with
one of the videos is the
the gimbal video which we can get into
later but it's a very simple thing which
is
uh when the the scene rotates can can
something that rotates the scene make
a glare rotate uh and the people are
told me that obviously
it can't that can't happen because if
you're rotating the entire scene
everything is going to rotate which is
true
but unfortunately they were asked the
wrong question
so we get this this situation where it's
not really dueling experts
here it's it's kind of people always
talking across purposes like i put
forward a hypothesis and someone doesn't
understand what it was but
they're not actually talking to me so we
can't we can't thresh it out so
i would love to talk to raytheon i would
love to talk to our
actual engineers uh i have heard people
who told me
that i uh i was right in various things
but they can't talk about it because
it's uh it's a classified system you
know the apflia system you know
the video that we're looking at right
now was taken with an afflea camera
uh which is a very expensive military
pod type glare effect
is simply to take uh your your camera
phone and
just kind of touch the lens on the back
it's actually it this is actually the
best footage that we have available from
that camera
we can't actually find any other footage
because it's a classified system and the
military does not release that footage
so
we've got this this opaque wall of
secrecy
beyond which i can't reach we have some
people who are a bit closer to that wall
and they can kind of look over it and we
have people on the other side
who can't actually talk about it at all
and so we've got this this big problem
of communication how do i get
how do i resolve you know whether i'm
right or wrong if no one can actually
talk about it
yeah and i think you know there is this
kind of deference to authority which by
the way does not have a place in the
scientific method
einstein was wrong no less than seven
times at least
by my reckoning he was of course right
many more times than that and
i point out in my book that he deserved
probably seven nobel prizes
according to most physicists and why he
didn't win that is a tale for another
time
but uh but similarly you know we could
make the same argument
for astronomers who as my friend sarah
scholes has made in her book they are
already here she was on my podcast last
year about her book which focuses on tom
de long and
and kind of the the um the features
there
you know astronomers are also experts at
watching the skies and we have advanced
technology that's not classified and in
fact
most of the technology that goes into
military hardware
has some pedigree some heritage that
traces its way to astronomical signals
for example the cosmic microwave
background that i study
was detected by accidents
serendipitously by two
radio astronomers and it's a through
line directly to
the cell phone that we're using many of
our listeners are watching right now on
to the devices in our pockets to this
very day
and the technology that went into the
first ccd cameras
those are all for astronomical image
sensing astronomers are watching the
skies
right now around the planet any clear
night of the day
and we use all wavelength bands and we
don't uh
have any less of an interest in fact
carl sagan one of the most eminent
astronomers of all time
uh jill tarter seth shostak who will be
on the into the impossible podcast
live tomorrow thursday and you're
welcome all of you listening out there
to join in
all these folks have been on my podcast
we astronomers would like nothing better
mick
than if this were true if we could have
access to advanced technology
if we could have access to new knowledge
and new laws of physics
this i mean if you were suppressing this
mick i would be more mad than any of the
comments that that come in negatively
against you
so i think uh to argue that you know
astronomers are suppressing this i think
that's that's sort of uh laughable
point no the government conspiracy
against it uh you have to give them
something right if they're saying well
the government's not going to give you
the fleer
because it's advanced technology i think
that's a little hollow this
image was taken these images were taken
in 2004
that probably means the raytheon
technology is over 30 years old right i
mean the flir system
itself was mounted on a pod it's not
installed on the f6
as i understand f18 this variant which
is the super hornet
as the upgrade first commis commissioned
in the 1980s
so this is not like some modern stealth
fighter right this is a pod that's
external to the original airframe
am i right yeah it fits underneath you
can take it on or off some some of the
planes that even have it on
uh but yeah it's it's uh it's it's just
a camera
essentially and so when we're talking
about you know what can it do or what
what can't it do uh there aren't that
many really
secret technological things that are
hidden and a lot of it was actually
described in the patents which
i read in in great depth and they
describe uh
to some degree the internal workings of
the system and how it uses these gimbal
mirrors internally to steer
the line of sight and how it has this
external gimbal and how they work
together
so it's it's not uh it's not like we
know nothing at all about it
but it'll be good to have confirmation
again part of the problem here is that
the what i'm describing is quite
complicated it was described by joe
rogan as
performing mental gymnastics which is a
term that's kind of caught on
for describing the these theories but uh
you know they are complicated
and it is difficult to explain and so
people then tend to
uh pick their expert and they pick which
person they want to
to agree with and of course like if it's
a choice between me and someone who you
know claims to be a flare technician or
someone who is a pilot
who is disagreeing with me they're going
to pick you know the pilot
i mean pick the the flare technician and
it could be simply that they prefer that
explanation but it's also because you
know this
this other person has a bit more
perceived authority than than me
so if we have explanations that are
competing
and we can't actually thrash them out in
the public sphere
then people are going to go with
opinions rather than actual facts
but you know if someone disagrees with
me they shouldn't just say i disagree
with you because i'm an expert
they should say i disagree with you and
here's why and here's the exact
technical reason why and then we can
discuss that and figure it out
one of the most troubling aspects as far
as experts in doubting the pilots to me
as you know i fly tiny little cessnas
right uh one of the things that
um that that troubled me is a report
that was on 60 minutes over time
and the fact that 60 minutes didn't have
any
uh as arthur c clarke would say equal
and opposite experts
meaning someone like you or someone just
to counter the narrative
that it either is the conspiracy
cover-up
we have right to foia right to know or
the two pilots uh three pilots
or more perhaps or lou i'm i'm blanking
on his last name
and probably would mispronounce it i'd
love to have him on the show as well
uh he's certainly you know a hero to
many people deservedly so
um but anyway there was nobody to point
out you know that uh
except in 60 minutes overtime and i can
put a link to that in the chat
you know that when they came back for
for several days the pilots were kind of
mocked
they were teased you know and and i
pointed out to my listeners and my
channel
uh last night i was chatting with them
in the comment section on my channel
and i said you know you can make fun of
me because i'm not a great pilot and i'm
not going to like criticize that or mick
you know and i you can say
like you have no right keating or mick
you have no right to criticize this
trained highly skilled pilot fravor
dietrich these are heroes these are top
guns literally
um but these are other pilots now
criticizing them teasing them um
making fun of them like i would never t
you never tease a pile about an accident
about an incident this could have led to
like tragic consequences right
so i'm wondering i can't criticize them
i can't you know because i'm not an
expert but these are other fighter
pilots right
now people are saying well pilots would
be pilots they'll tease each other but
come on at some point
you you have to start to say well like
you know what point do we trust the
eyewitness testimony
and what point you know do we we have to
rely on sensor data
now there are questions in the chat room
people are asking well what about the
radar data is that not
reliable that's not eyewitness data
that's cold
hard time series evidence mick what do
you say about that
uh the radar data is eyewitness data
because we don't actually have access to
it and we don't
even know anybody who has access to it
now we perhaps louis elizondo is
claiming that he has seen something
but if you uh if we talk about say the
nimitz incident which is david fravis
incident
we have recollections about what the
radar looked like you know what
showed up on the scope and what showed
up when they did replays
of it but we don't actually have the
data so
you know really is that is that
recollection of a radar reading any
different from an eyewitness seeing
something
in the sky you know it's additional
information but it's just an additional
eyewitness
uh statement we don't actually have the
corroborating data we you know if we
have the if we have the video and we had
like you know video of the radar screen
showing the same thing at the same time
that would be wonderful
that would be really really good if it
showed something amazing it was just
showing you know dots in the distance
that wouldn't be that amazing
but you know we don't actually have the
data but people talk about that all the
time we have
eyewitness accounts of seeing things in
the sky
we have eyewitness accounts of radar
data
and we have this this one kind of fuzzy
video
of something which doesn't actually
doesn't actually happen at the same time
as either the eyewitness account
or uh the the eyewitness accounts of the
radar data
so um now the time series data is that
not available
to you know foia requests or something i
mean i can imagine that
you know after 17 years might not be
uh super threatening uh but you know
have is that something that you've
pursued as well mike to try to gain
access to
i haven't but i know other people have
people have been trying to get this this
information
out uh you know for for years uh these
this information you know if it was
there
it's just it's just the type of thing
that is um
classified or not cleared for release by
default and there's just no
there's no reason for the military to
release it i i don't know if that would
even be
foiable because it's something that's
you know essentially an
active operation even if it's a training
operation i don't know if that would be
something that they would release
i guess they have released deck logs of
some
incidents but they also retract parts of
those
redact uh so i yeah well it would be
great if we could have that and if
anybody out there has got any idea how
to get it then yeah let's get it but we
do not have radar data now
let's see there's a question my cyrillic
is not that great but i think it's anton
spasiba anton is asking a question why
not make a collaborative research effort
with between mick and some
former ttsa members have you thought
about doing that reaching out to the
intelligence community
well yeah ttsa isn't the intelligence
community though that's the the to the
stars academy
oh to the sorry i'm sorry yeah uh which
i thought it was uh transportation
safety administration
that would be the tsa uh yeah
yeah i would i'd be happy to collaborate
with anybody if they've got like some
ideas or information that they want to
share or they want to work over
but know i've talked to someone that
i've talked to louie alexander i
interviewed him
uh i tried to get chris mellon uh you
know to talk and i've emailed a few of
the other people and i'd be happy to
talk to any of them
but i don't think they like me and i
think part of that is because
uh i'm a destroyer of destroyer of
dreams when it comes to ufo videos i i
take these videos and i give a
mundane explanation of it and this isn't
my intent
i don't go in there thinking like oh
well i'm going to destroy somebody's
dreams today
i go there and look at these videos and
say what is this thing
and try to figure out what it is and
perhaps because i'm a bit more
obsessive and have a little bit more
time on my hands than other people have
i often kind of arrive at an answer and
often with the help
of other people a lot of people
contribute to these investigations
and you know turns out a lot of these
videos are pretty mundane explanations
when tcsa uh people like elizondo and
melon have been claiming in the past
that they share extraordinary things
which would be indicative of some kind
of amazing technology
or even aliens now getting back to the
eyewitness accounts
you know which i think uh i think it is
believed that
those are some of the more convincing
accounts right because you're basically
saying
the radar data shouldn't should count as
eyewitness data right you're saying the
operators are testifying
we don't have the raw data we don't have
the time series data as you might
expect correct yeah we don't we don't
have data that we can actually analyze
and do some kind of reconstruction we
have people's recollections of it which
is certainly more than
just eyewitness uh you know eyeballs on
the thing we
we have uh actual people talking about
the radar for example when fraver went
out
to see an object he was sent to a
location because there was a radar
return at that location and it was one
of these
in the nimitz encounter they had these
groups of five radar returns which were
slowly drifting down from the north to
the south which they initially thought
might be some kind of
glitch in the system they reset the
system and then it you know stayed and
they
they thought that might be balloons or
something they couldn't figure it out
and eventually they sent a jet out this
is the story the recollection that
people give
and then fraber went to the location and
then at approximately that location
he saw something down by the water and
that turned out to be the tic tac and
alex dietrich was was there with him and
she saw
something along the same lines now the
altitude and so forth i mean i'd love to
have on
those individuals and i'm hoping and
working to get
to to be with them but i'm trying to
work out just the geometry of it you've
done
yeoman's work on uh you know reproducing
the glare
and lens flare and ghosting the bokeh
we'll get into that in just a bit
um and uh but looking at it in in terms
of you know from a pilot's perspective
how how would one actually approach this
literally you know flying a high
performance jet low
over the ocean uh tracking you know
during a daytime encounter
uh for an object which was reported the
size of a of
a of an f-18 um you know with no scale
nothing to compare to on a featureless
ocean surface
um you know where you're flying a
supersonic jet
uh capable of extremely high speeds at
what's called high angle of attack so
the only way to fly a very fast jet very
slow as would be needed would be to make
it dirty which is to
have landing gear and flaps spoilers
leading edge devices etc deployed
and then fly it at high angle of attack
or high alpha which puts the cockpit at
a high
um high pitch with respect to the ocean
so that's not
really compatible and i'm wondering you
know people have actually simulated
you know what would the encounter look
like just from a just from an aviation
perspective what is the geometry
involved you know what did it look like
from the cockpit because it wasn't like
you know it's imagine driving down the
freeway
and you're looking for something the
size of a car or two cars
and you're going the stall speed of an
f18 in that configuration
which is its landing configuration is
still about 100 knots or so
and so he'd have to be going faster than
that or he would stall and he wouldn't
be here god forbid
um so you're going 200 maybe 200 knots
uh 230 miles an hour
to stay safe and then you're still at a
pitch up angle if you're not deploying
your
all your drag devices so has anyone
looked at
what is the geometry involved and what
would it look like in the cockpit the
cockpit is not like a
glass bubble he's got a lot of stuff in
his face he's got a heads-up display
has anyone looked at that well i think
you know the cockpit kind of is
the top half of it is kind of a glass
bubble and the pilot does actually sit
relatively high because they do need to
have very good visibility in the air
space around them so it's not like they
can't see
out of the side and the angle of attack
perhaps isn't so much of an issue
at the front because when fraber says he
saw it at first he says he looked out of
the side window
and saw it so he would have had a
reasonable view of the ocean and i think
even if you're going at 200 to 300 knots
uh we're looking down at the ocean at
something that is 20 000 feet below and
you know a few
a few thousand feet to the side so say
it's about you know four or five miles
away visually
so even if you're going fairly fast yeah
in your field of view the the rate of
change of the
of the angle of the the object isn't
going to be that much so you would be
able to
to keep an eyeball on it if you could
see it in the first place
and they didn't actually see the object
itself first the the tic tac
object they saw what they described as
being a excuse me a disturbance in the
water so they looked down
and they saw what looked like either
waves breaking over something or some
kind of
boiling in the water uh type disturbance
like a submarine surfacing or whales
feeding or something like that
and then they saw this this tic-tac
object uh above
this disturbance in the water so you
could imagine that you know this this
larger disturbance would catch their eye
and then they saw this this smaller tic
tac so i think uh you know it's
it's you know plausible that they saw
something and certainly seeing something
in the water
but then when it gets complicated is
like you say they're
looking at something where you have no
context uh
as to how big it is you know it's a tic
tac i've got this this is like an iphone
case i'm holding up here uh
tic-tac-shaped
and uh yeah you know how big it is
because you know how big my hand is
but if this was just you know hovering
in space and you know it was there was
blue sky behind it and you didn't know
how far away it was if this was like say
you know back on my shelf over here it
would actually be a lot bigger
than what you see here it would be like
you know four times as big
but because you know where it is uh you
excuse me
didn't use my skype though uh because
because you know what the context is you
can figure out how big it is but if you
lack that context you cannot actually
you cannot actually find out uh uh how
how big it is and if you don't know how
big something is you don't know how far
away it is
and vice versa if you don't know how far
away it is you don't know how big it is
now fraver says that he looked at this
thing
and he knew it was 40 feet well and he
was asked by lex friedman like how did
you know this and his answer was
um 15 years experience as a pilot
as a navy pilot top gun pilot right and
uh you know it's just kind of fair
enough but how actually do you know
how do you know is there some kind of
technique that you use is do you
reference something else or you just you
look at this thing
you have no idea what it is no idea what
uh
how big it is but you instantly know how
big it is by by magic you somehow
essentially
you know the fragra then goes on to talk
about uh in this same
interview with lex fridman about how you
you can't
actually trust your eyes pretty much
how often do you do you trust your eyes
need how often do you make mistakes and
and and uh and fraga was saying you know
all the time
yeah he says you were actually trained
not to trust our eyes because your eyes
fool you in aviation
he was talking about other stuff and
saying like you know we go down
when he went down because he didn't go
all the way down to the surface of the
ocean because you're
you always stop before you get too close
to the ocean because people lose spatial
awareness as to how high they are and
they fly into the ocean he said that
happens all the time
right so if he knows about all these
visual illusions that can happen how
does he know something like that didn't
actually happen to him
yeah although they have radar altimeters
in the f-18 and
there are many ways to do it but yes
you're right as a pilot the first lesson
you get is trust your instruments that's
why we have exactly
instruments that's why you use the
altimeter rather than looking to see
where the ocean is when you're
descending towards the ocean when you
try to land at an airport
yeah you you're using you're generally
using things
uh like like the the landing aids that
are on the side of the airport on the
other hand you know i am
i am torn right you would like to have
there not be a stigma
you know if there are some in let's say
it's it's not you know exotic phenomena
let's say it is you know chinese drones
or
you know let's say those you know
portuguese i don't know why we always
have to you know stigmatize that there's
you know these nefarious enemies trying
to let's say it's those damn portuguese
people again they're trying to get back
you know the new world and
they've got sophisticated anti-aircraft
you know
anyway uh and so they're harassing it so
you wouldn't want to make it so that you
know the next time
an f-35 pilot is out there that she's
not going to report it right so
you don't want to stigmatize it no yeah
i i'm all for that i'm all for reporting
these incidents because i think
uh the more that they can be reported
the more we can clear up what's actually
going on because i think there are very
real issues here
if fraver you know saw something and it
wasn't identical
that needs to be figured out they should
have followed it up they should have
tried to figure out what was going on
maybe they did
so uh you know either there was a
failure there in doing that
or they already knew what it was i think
it's
probably the former they probably just
didn't take him seriously
and they didn't follow up with with uh
with investigating it
so i think you know if pilots are seeing
things that are unidentified
that is an issue uh sometimes that is
going to be the pilots themselves making
mistakes
sometimes it might be issues with
equipment and sometimes it might
actually be
be real things and it could be just you
know different ways of looking at things
that we haven't really like thought
about
before like you know perhaps sometimes
uh we get certain atmospheric effects
which do
you know make make something appear like
a flying saucer off in the distance
so yeah we should definitely look into
these things
so just a reminder take a little pause
we're speaking with mick west
who's got a wonderful youtube channel
which you may find
uh wherever youtube's videos are
sold and bought i am brian keating
the proprietor of the into the
impossible podcast
and you can find me dr brian keating on
youtube and
on twitter and mick west mcwest on
twitter
and on youtube as well tomorrow i'm
going to be interviewing
seth shostak of the seti institute
who along with jill tarter has been a
long time guest and friend of the arthur
c clarke center for human imagination
which i co-direct
i'm the chancellor's distinguished
professor of physics and astrophysicist
with uh also with 25 years of flying
small planes not far from the warning
area where
the tic tac encounter was spot although
it wasn't me and i can prove it because
i
was not able to fly that particular day
uh i'm going to play a little video
interlude
thank everybody for joining us and uh
ask you to tune in to the
arthur c clark center for human
imagination and also subscribe to my
channel
leave a comment do you think these uh
these encounters represent
advanced technology either earthbound or
not earthbound
and i want to speculate if mick will
allow me and kind of think about what
would be the implications if these
uh are actually representative of
technology
not of our current generation or of our
current
um current technological capabilities
before i go there though i do want to
ask a question
that is being asked in the chat room uh
because there are so many questions
coming in i want to thank you all for
putting up
your questions in the chat room and
um i will thank you i'm sorry i'm a
little bit too loud here
so array gray is asking what do you
think of the most foundational ufo
cases ariel school siding phoenix
west hall uh school sighting forest rend
hall sighting
rent rendelshim sighting how much weight
do you give to any of these sightings
well you know a lot of these things are
um
i eyewitness only accounts the aerial
school sighting was a lot of school
children who saw something
and the uh the reynoldshum forest
citing like i think has some maybe very
limited imagery but again it was mostly
eyewitness accounts
and a lot of these these sightings are
very very old
and i personally you know while you know
i don't
don't want to just dismiss them out of
hand i'm not particularly interested in
these old sightings because the evidence
that's available for analysis isn't very
good
the aerial school one for example the
evidence consists of
a bunch of children telling the story of
what they they
thought they saw and some pictures
that the the children drew and there's
no there's no physical evidence there's
no
there's no adult witnesses and there's
no you know videos or photos so that was
a very difficult one to get any
any handle on and you'd have to talk to
like child psychiatrists and memory
experts
as to you know the validity of their
eyewitness accounts but you know
personally i don't
i don't think it's particularly
compelling uh and
i i just you know i'm not actually
really that much of a ufo guy when it
comes down to it
uh i only really got into it four years
ago i i'm not deeply seeked in the the
history of ufos
uh although i've been reading a lot
recently because it's so fascinating but
what i'm really into is studying videos
and so that naturally means that i
i look at the newer cases because the
newer cases are the ones that have
videos
so when we think about um
let me get rid of my middle and i just
got teleported
an extra copy of me just emerged here um
so some other questions are coming in
about uh
about the famous boca green pyramid
which i thought you did a masterful kind
of analysis with
actually making use of free astronomical
toolkits like
stellarium and loading positions the
only thing i thought was missing was
just the analysis of
an arrival what's called an arrival
corridor where aircraft arrive
on pre-defined set flight paths and the
fact that many of these aircraft
that fly in what's called controlled
airspace which the tic tac
encounter by the way was not within if
it was conducted at the surface
is in what's called the so-called
warning area which anybody who has a
pilot's license can operate in
they do so at great risk um and that uh
that risk is is to you know potential
life and limb that you may be
intercepted you may be shot you may be
intercepted not illegally but you may be
intercepted as a sort of a cat playing
with a mouse
and that would be uh that that would be
for practice for these naval aviators
uh but you're legally allowed to operate
in this warning area
and but you may be shot with a missile
by accident
because they can't guarantee your safety
but above 18 000 feet if this object
really did ascend to 60 000 feet for
example but
other things like the bokeh if you want
to explain that i'll put the video up
i'm having trouble muting my
uh your video but i'll put that up on
screen the bokeh and i'll i'll just play
it without sound on my side
uh you want to talk about that or do
would you rather talk about the gimbal
which which one is sort of more
uh yeah the work is interesting because
it's new but yeah real quick i actually
used to uh
fly in that area myself i didn't really
fly over the ocean very much i'd go out
and look at the dolphins occasionally
but uh yeah around uh 2003 2004
yeah coincidentally the exact same time
with the nimitz encounter i was taking
flying lessons out of santa monica
so i'm kind of familiar with the the
layout of the airspace there and you
know you fly out of santa monica you've
got the class b
beneath you so you never really get down
to the warning area but
yeah it's very busy airspace which is
one of the things about it because
obviously you've got
not only lax but you have uh you have
long beach uh john wayne airport and
then you have san diego and then a few
other airports as well you sometimes
get people flying from hawaii to denver
flying overhead as well and then you get
people flying overhead from from the
north to san diego
very very busy airspace so there's lots
of things to see
uh in the sky yeah and you know that
kind of brings us to the
the boca video the triangle video okay
it's this green night vision
which one uh should i play here i'm
gonna put the
i have the bokeh on let me see here i'm
gonna do screenshots uh
yeah yeah that one's this one's this
one's good this so this what you what
you're seeing there is me actually
taking the video and trying to track
where it was
in the the star field and if you go to
the start of that video this i think
it's just me yeah there's just the full
full trace like right at the start of
that video you actually see
a bunch of stars and the planet jupiter
and somebody else noticed this before i
did and they pointed out
that this was you know this actual
constellation and that the
that uh jupiter was there on that
particular day night june 15
2019 and so we knew exactly where the
camera was looking and then we were able
to trace the camera through the sky
and see where it ended up and where it
ended up there was two other stars
uh right at the end of the of the uh
the the video and you see the flashing
triangle
pass by these two other stars and these
two of the stars
also take on the shape of triangles and
this was kind of originally presented
when the video came out as these are
two other crafts that are not flashing
and are just hovering there
but you can see by doing this trace
through it that there are actually these
these two stars
i don't think they're actually labeled
in this version of the video but you
know you can actually you'll see it pass
by one of them in a second
uh and yeah we know exactly what the
stars are
we know uh what we're looking at and we
know what angle we're looking at because
we know what time of day it is
roughly uh so we can get a good idea of
uh
you know what we're actually looking at
in terms of
altitude and angular speed and whatnot
but you're stepping back a bit
besides knowing where it is in the sky
and the fact that the triangle shape
of the the object is kind of an optical
artifact which is obvious from
the stars being made into triangles by
the camera uh
we also see that it's flashing and it's
flashing in a very similar way
to uh the flashing of
a commercial plane like a boeing 737
there's
they don't have strict ways that they
have to flash they just have limits
between which you have plus between
something like 30 and
70 times per second or something like
that they have a limit
and different manufacturers have
different types of lights there's led
lights and there's the xenon lights
uh but yeah basically the bottom line is
uh the flashing pattern looks like a
plane
the triangular shape of this object
comes
from an artifact of the camera it has a
triangular
aperture like the the aperture of uh of
the lens is triangular
uh you know some some lenses have more
circular
apertures like which is octagonal one
here
this one's a triangular one so when you
take pictures of small lights that are
out of focus they will appear as
triangles
uh and that's that's what we're seeing
here so
all these things kind of line up and
then we know the rough location of the
plane
uh the of the boat that where where the
video is taken is the uss russell and we
have the deck logs from those two days
and we have the location and
in latitude and longitude of that and so
you can stick it on the map and we can
go back into the
the the flight to flight trapping apps
like plane finder planefinder.net
you can replay back to that day and you
can see exactly which planes were flying
overhead and a whole bunch of planes
on that particular day it varies based
on the wind and other factors
but on that day there were a whole bunch
of planes basically flying directly
overhead
that area so everything lines up you've
got a triangular shaped flashing light
that's uh moving it's moving a plane
speed we can do that we can do the whole
uh translate the angular velocity to
to linear velocity and it works out to
be right if it's at the
same altitude as the planes uh we know
there were planes in that region at the
time
and we know that this is simply a a
small light that has been turned into a
triangular shape which is what
a a plane would look like and beyond
that
we have a whole bunch of people who have
this type of of night vision camera with
a triangular aperture
this is just a lens not a night vision
camera but they have these night vision
cameras with triangular apertures
they've gone out
they've taken pictures of the night sky
with stars and planes and it looks
exactly the same
as this video so i i really don't feel
like there's very much room
for alternative explanations here and
yet
people won't let it go
so i want to switch topics to your book
escaping the rabbit hole
we want to talk about that for a little
bit what is that about what impelled you
to write it
uh what is the guide to helping friends
family and loved ones why do you want
them to escape doesn't it sort of uh
you know kind of depend on what they
believe and uh
why why why uh why why did you write
this book
well uh it's really about helping people
who have been trapped in some kind of
conspiracy theory rabbit hole they've
come to believe things
which are not true like say an extreme
example someone believes that the earth
is flat
and they're going around saying that the
earth is flat
everyone makes fun of them because of
this they become socially isolated
because the
people think that they are idiots they
they try to persuade other people that
the earth is flat they don't trust
anything that science says so they
start distrusting every single thing
that's that's out there in science
and so uh i think it's a worthwhile
thing
trying to help them get out of that
belief now that's an extreme belief
there are lots of other uh conspiracy
theory beliefs that are out there that
are less extreme
for example some people believe that the
world trade center was
destroyed by the us government using
pre-planted explosives
you know this is something that people
actually believe so it's conspiracy
theory that people believe
and if you start believing that again
you start uh
having all this very anti-social for
into the better word
but if if if you start you know having
this deep-seated distrust of the
government you can kind of go south in a
in a very in a very short space of time
if you think back to a long time ago
there was the oklahoma city bombing
which i think was in the 1990s uh maybe
the early 2000s the 1990s yeah but that
that was the my timothy mcveigh
and he was a believer in conspiracy
theories he thought
that the u.s government was in league
with the united nations and was going to
enslave everybody
and he was sending a message to to the
powers that be that you know he wasn't
going to take it
so these conspiracy theories have
consequences both for the individual and
for society as a whole
and so something i've i've actually been
interested in
in general is just how do you talk to
people who believe in conspiracy
theories and you know kind of what i've
learned over the years is that
the key thing to do is first of all keep
talking
you know maintain an effective
communication with people
and uh don't don't get into a position
where you're arguing with them straight
away
because until you reach some kind of
mutual understanding you're not going to
get anywhere
so the first thing you've got to do is
like keep talking second thing you've
got to do is try to figure out figure
them out try to understand them
and or and on the flip side try to
explain to
them where you are coming from but
always do it in this context of keeping
the conversation going
and then when you kind of establish that
and you've got some kind of common
ground you can then move on to kind of
the
the second step of the process which is
supplying them with useful information
which is
if they they say something which is
wrong you can at this point know you've
established effective communication you
can respectfully
introduce other opinions and facts and
then talk about them you know they're
not necessarily going to agree with it
but you can talk about it
and then the third step here in my
three-step program is to give it time
because these things take a lot more
time than you would initially think you
think you could just go in there
explain to someone why they're wrong and
they'll be like oh yeah but no it
doesn't work like that you explain to
them why they're wrong and they say
you're a government shill
and they stop talking to you so it's a
kid gloves
process that takes a lot of time uh want
to remind folks we're talking with mick
west who's got his
own podcast he's got his own book and
he's got his own youtube channel
a competitor to mine uh but i do hope
that you will tune in to both subscribe
to both even though it's a zero zom game
mech
hopefully we'll find some fertile cross
pollination i want to ask a question
that is being asked by a listener
um who has a name that i was gonna
choose for my first born
son his name is boiled pizza which is
making me hungry
uh to be honest but he asked a question
which i'll rephrase a little bit
uh mick i want to ask you which uh
debate opponent on the
other side of the ufo aisle would you
most fear
or do you most uh feel is most kind of
intimidating to your
uh against your arguments um
well i don't know i i i talked recently
with oh gosh i remember forget his name
now
um but the guy from the the scu i i must
apologize to him but uh
uh robert i think something but you know
he was a guy who had been kind of
asking me for a long time to have a
debate with him because you know he felt
like he could
uh obliterate me and we had you know a
reasonable chat and we we threshed out a
few things and we had some disagreements
and some agreements
i don't like to debate people i like to
have discussions with them
yeah i think there's no point trying to
you know try to
try to be like who has the best argument
here we're not lawyers in a courtroom
trying to present a case trying to get
someone off you know lawyers
have to just look at one side i don't
want to look at just one side i want to
figure out what's going on i'm not a
lawyer i'm an investigator i'm someone
who's trying to figure out
what actually happened in these cases uh
so if anybody wants to talk to me
that's fine i mean if they wouldn't they
want to argue with me that's fine too
like i don't i don't mind that
you know if they want to try to point
out where i'm wrong that's great
because if people are pointing out where
i'm wrong we can have a discussion about
that and we can say
you know am i actually wrong maybe maybe
not or maybe i am and if i am
i'll revise my position and move on
very good uh so we have a couple more
questions from the audience and i will
also conclude with some questions of my
own
so cooperating with the to the stars
academy which you corrected me about of
course
uh is not out of the question you would
love to have them
uh uh collaborate with you but so far
they have not uh accepted
what do you make of harry reid and and
uh you know getting involved in this uh
kind of make strange bedfellows with
marco rubio is that uh
did that pique your interest yeah well i
mean harry reid
has been a ufo enthusiast for a long
time he got into
ufos back in 1996 when he i think first
went to ufo convention with
his friend george knapp who's a local
las vegas journalist
and he he has a friend uh rob bigelow
was the guy behind
the atip program who got the original
atip
contract so you know he's he's been a
ufo enthusiast for a long time
uh i don't know about strange bedfellows
with with rubio it's it's kind of
in a way a kind of an apolitical issue
um
so you know if republicans want to get
interested in it then i i don't think
they're going to be particularly you
know upset that they're working with
democrats on it
uh you have rubio and you have mark
warner who is the actual chief of the
intelligence committee
now that rubio was when trump was
president
and you know they're basically saying
the same thing that there are
things that the military can't always
identify and uh
that we should look into this because
like i said earlier
it's an issue so yeah i don't really see
any kind of
political uh problem there
and what do you say to those that
criticize you because you're a video
game
designer i mean uh for example i heard
fravor
comment on you uh well you know the the
tic tac analysis that you did
you know the plane is is you have the
gimbal but the plane is not
it's not banking it's just sort of
pivoting and aircraft don't really do
that
which is true and you know that as a
pilot as well so what do you say to that
well uh video game programming is
actually fairly complicated
there's a lot of a lot of stuff going on
in there so the the and the mathematics
that we're talking about in terms of
things like gimbal rotation and
the axis of rotation and
three-dimensional transforms
uh are just the exact same types of
things that i do in video game
programming so i may not know the nuts
and bolts
of you know what button to press in the
cockpit but i understand
what happens when a mirror rotates or i
understand what happens when when a
camera rotates and i understand what
gimbal lock is
and i can read i can read the patterns
and i can see what's going on
inside inside these cameras now framer
is great at
operating the equipment but that doesn't
mean he necessarily knows every nuance
of what might happen
uh to it in various unusual situations
like with with the gimbal
uh i don't think he really had a good
rebuttal of uh
the fact that there is this gimbal role
in fact he explicitly said that the
there wasn't a gimbal role transition
when you go past
zero degrees and yet in underwater video
which he's very familiar with
you can actually see the gimbal role
happen you see the entire sky rotate
much more dramatically in fact than in
the gimbal video so
he's missing something that's right
there in front of his face
and i think if i was to be able to sit
down with him and respectfully
go through it with him i'm sure he could
show me things but i think i could
probably show him a few things as well
yeah i mean from a physics perspective
which is the way i hope to engage you
know i can't engage
other than the tools that i have which
are you know from the perspective of an
astrophysicist
who's very learned in general relativity
quantum mechanics
uh thermodynamics etc you know these
objects
are you know potentially traversing you
know
if they're you know truly described by
interstellar phenomena
they would have to traverse vast
distances be controlled remotely
uh be autonomous because you know
they'd have to have some purpose in mind
and then they're operating in a very
narrow
you know region of the earth's
mesosphere um in very short durations
but then they happen to be
in a very very narrow uh region of
one country's warning areas um
you know that's defined by a obscure
administration
agency of the federal government um and
and they seem to show up preferentially
in one country
um and they don't show up you know when
venus is below the horizon as often
they don't show up outside of certain
flight paths um
and what do you make of also this kind
of uh resurgence of
of interest of course you know david
kaiser is professor of science
technology as well as physics at mit uh
wrote a book
recently quantum legacies about the how
the atom and splitting the atom and the
quantum revolution
uh led to many similar related phenomena
both the threat of nuclear holocaust but
also
the resurgence or the surge of interest
in radar
in ufos etc and now we kind of see a new
uh twin paradox coming about where we
have a resurgence
or a surge in interest in interplanetary
uh uh travel a courtesy of spacex
perhaps
we have exploration going back to the
moon not the space age space race
originally
we have uh hopes for fusion reactors on
earth we have hopes for
artificial intelligence machine learning
it's sort of like paralleling
the post-war dayton but cold war instead
of russia we may have china as we've
said
um do you make of it that you know kind
of this arises in amelia
of vast technological kind of what they
call future shock
is that to be expected in in such a
milieu
i think so uh but i'm not sure that's
what's happening here i'm not sure
what's
with the current ufo flap it's actually
really any difference to
the the ufo flaps of the 1940s and 1950s
now back in the the 40s and 50s we we
had a very
um kind of interesting technological
uh backdrop which was the the threat of
nuclear weapons and the
the promise of nuclear power uh so
we we had this kind of new technology
and a lot of people theorized at the
time that
uh flying saucers were actually russian
nuclear-powered planes
and that somehow the russians had done
this technological leap which is
something people theorize now that uh
what we're seeing is an adversary who
has developed
some kind of warp drive so it's very it
seems very very similar but i don't
think there's this kind of similar
backdrop
uh in in terms of an advancing
technology
i mean sure there's the the space uh
spacex aspect of it but
and that's contributed but i think more
spacex has contributed because of the
the spacex satellites and the
the constellation trains of satellites
are still being mistaken for ufos
my feeling isn't really the there's this
this big
big shift in technology which is being
represented by a shift in
in perceptions of of ufos i think what
we're seeing now is really essentially
uh
uh the result of a fairly good pr
program by the the groups of people who
are interested
in in ufo disclosure i mean going back
to harry reid
and rob bigelow and you know tom de long
and and luella zonda people like that
they're doing a good job of getting it
out there in the media
uh tim wilson is saying uh the names of
the videos go fast gimbal
are clear indications that the
department of defense realize what they
are
and they are trolling people what do you
make of that
uh it could be that the the names of the
videos
represent what's actually in them in
terms of uh
the analysis of them like the go fast
video i mean you could think of that
both ways because go fast
looks like it's going fast so if they
were really trolling people they would
call it go slow
because it's actually going slow and
that would be the real explanation
the gimbal video i think is is perhaps
the more telling file name
and these are actually the file names
that were released by the dod
uh and because the the rotation of the
gimbal craft
uh appears to be a gimbal lock
and a gimbal lock artifact the camera
traverses zero degrees it has to rotate
as it at some time while it passes zero
degrees and that causes
uh the horizon to rotate relative to
that the camera
which means that the glares are now at
an angle relative to the horizon
and then the derotation mechanism has to
rotate the horizon back which means that
the glare is now rotated
in the scene relative to where it was
before so
yeah that it could well be that this
this file name
gimbal represents the actual explanation
of what is going on in the video
uh so we have a question from philip
shane who is a good friend and host of
the what the if
uh podcast and let me see if i can call
up
his um his this question so philip is
asking would noah be a proper
national oceanographic and atmospheric
administration
would they be a proper agency to
investigate um uaps
and i think that uaps he's saying should
be called
unidentified atmospheric phenomena
well that's certainly a possibility and
you know a lot of the times when people
point to things in the sky they are
actually pointing at atmospheric
phenomena they're pointing at things
like clouds or things like uh
inversion layers causing some kind of
mirage like a like a fatter morgana
type mirage or superior mirage where
something that's on the horizon appears
like it's floating way up above
it so i don't think obviously that
every single ufo is some kind of
atmospheric phenomena
but certainly people who are experts in
that that type of thing and noaa could
be involved in the discussion and nasa
has a lot of atmospheric scientists
as well so yeah i think a europa
uap task force of any any any
quality would have an atmospheric
scientist on board
and the last uh sort of question that um
someone's asking if you would like a tic
tac
i think that's not called for i think
that's weight out of order
nobody wants a tic tac right now this
podcast is sponsored by
by bubblicious of course um i want to i
am a big fan of tic tacs actually i have
my empty box
that i just finished earlier with the
gum of choice you need a
need a new supply so thank you for those
super chats i'll make sure
mick gets a tick an attack i'm sorry i
said tik tok later that earlier
that must have been i was talking too
much about chinese that's why i'm being
so nice and saying the portuguese are
responsible for all this
um so i also want to talk just the last
points about kind of the scientific
method scientific results
i think there is sort of a wish
fulfillment in some sense that
um as i said earlier no astronomer worth
his or her salt would turn down
you know the opportunity to study these
phenomena uh first of all be
instantaneous tenure i have a colleague
here
professor shelly wright she studies
optical study she's looking for burst of
light
not far from where you are at the lick
observatory
looking for blasts of light from alien
civilizations
uh this is legitimate scientific study
uh it has been
studied for 60 years plus and tomorrow
when seth shostak comes on the podcast
i'm going to ask him uh when this was
conceived in the 1960s frank drake and
others
philip morrison and others they thought
it would be maybe a quick search and and
it was kind of spare time on telescopes
radio telescopes
it's now lasted you know in the seventh
decade when do you stop searching um
because there is a phenomena look
elsewhere you know if you look long
enough you will start to see
three sigma standard deviation type
effects
but you know is that justifiable is that
self-justifiable is there a sunk cost
hypothesis
i know this isn't your field but you
know when do you stop looking or when do
you double down what do you think about
the search for extraterrestrial
intelligence totally distinct from what
you and i have been talking about
yeah well i think uh that there's
there's two two
searches really there's the search out
there and then there's the search here
and you know the ufo stuff is obviously
the search here but the external search
i think
is something that you know where i would
never stop looking for that i don't i
don't think
you're ever going to exhaust the the
data sets that are out there
or you're not going to exhaust different
ways of looking for things like
different ways of looking
for signatures in exoplanet atmospheres
and
deep variants in in
solar radiation from from other stars
for things like dyson spheres and
whatnot
uh various dyson structures so there's
always going to be things to look for
uh i think yeah sure like you might get
some kind of false positive
eventually but that doesn't mean that
you you don't stop looking it just means
that's just another data point
because it's not going to prove its
people because you know people will do
that do the math and you know figure out
that that doesn't actually
uh prove that something exists out there
and you you
follow up with the experiment you'd look
in the same bit of the sky and you see
what else is out there
so i i'm a big science fiction fan like
i said
big arthur c clarke uh fan my one of my
favorite books when i was younger was
rendezvous with rama
and i just love the idea of uh of aliens
and
i think we should keep looking so i want
to build on a question by uh
tim as well but i want to ask you know
your game designer
uh let's fast forward you know 20
millennia
let's let's apply moore's law you know
what do video games look like what does
uh what does you know computational
technology look like what does ar
look like um what if there are you know
advances
uh keeping a pace first of all is it
possible can we keep progressing
according to moore's law
just thinking about video games yeah
well uh
you think about i mean video games are
essentially simulations of reality
and you know what we're talking about
here is is getting more and more
high fidelity simulations that more
closely uh
resemble the real world and uh
yeah moore's law does does have certain
physical limits you you can't keep
making transistors smaller and smaller
because you know atoms
uh are not device divisible in terms of
you know
silicon but uh you can have massively
parallel computation and you can
extend that out almost indefinitely and
all it requires is space
material and energy uh so we could build
theoretically in the future very very
large computers that could use
like like i was mentioned the dyson
sphere which is a sphere that
encompasses a star to use all of the
energy
that the star is putting out you could
make a
um a supercomputer which was the size of
a dyson sphere which would
be incredibly incredibly large and you
could do
a very impressive video game with a
computer that size
i don't know who would be playing it but
essentially what you're talking about
there is a simulation
that is indistinguishable from reality
you know you know of course that leads
you to the simulation hypothesis are we
living in a simulation now
uh but yeah i think yeah
perhaps like you know going along those
lines you think could aliens
have developed some kind of
supercomputer like that and if they have
like probably it that supercomputer is
going to be vastly more intelligent
than those aliens themselves were if you
get enough computing power
and you structure the thing right you're
going to get hyper intelligence which is
vastly more powerful than
than than humans which makes the case
that
i think if aliens do arrive they will
probably arrive in the form of
super-intelligent robots rather than
aliens themselves
and thinking about uh you know kind of
the
the end game of where this goes do you
think it's more likely than not
that the net result of this
release purportedly coming very soon
perhaps
in a next day or two would be would be
almost amounting to just a confirmation
of what's been
already talked about in other words that
the pentagon could essentially
just release what's already been
released maybe wrap it up with some you
know government stamp with some
redacted tape put over some some some
splotches and
satisfy the rubio commission and so
forth
or do you think you know they basically
have to release something as eric
weinstein has said
you know how do we how do we you know
kind of uh
troll the the state and say oh we've got
all this information we're going to
release it but then simultaneously
release almost nothing i mean
isn't that basically uh beyond the pale
of what a government could do
to its citizens well they haven't said
that they've got all this information uh
louie elizondo has said he's got
all the information but he's not in the
pentagon anymore he's uh he
you know he left it several years ago uh
various other people have said things
but the actual pentagon hasn't really
said that they've got lots of
information they're going to release
they said they're going to cooperate
with the inquiry
and they're going to do what was
mandated by congress so you've got to
look at what
what does the bill actually ask and
essentially it's asking for
details of investigations into into uaps
which you know they but they don't have
to give you
stuff that is classified they could have
a classified annex which is a data
repository
of all the classified stuff so uh i
don't think that they are
obligated in any way to give some kind
of huge data dump if that's what eric
weinstein was saying i think what we're
likely to get
is is basically a an overview of the
situation
i hope it is one that puts things in
correct context
and doesn't engage in speculation uh
i think it will probably talk about the
real issues that we have within
identified objects like you know drones
and airspace
airspace incursions and pilots uh not
being able to identify things
and um i i do not anticipate
that things will change very much
because i think what will happen is that
the
ufo fans are going to get angry that not
a lot enough was released
and i will probably be a bit
disappointed that they
didn't actually clear things up a bit
more and we'll just go on from there
yeah so you know i've had on as i said
many different uh
perspectives from perspectives differing
on
the properties of bitcoin from michael
saylor to gold on pitter schiff
from proponents of string theory like
michio kaku
to opponents of string theory like avi
loeb who also has
conjectures about alien techno
signatures and maybe we could talk about
that for a second
um ufos are the ultimate form of techno
signatures right so
it surprises me that that the foremost
proponents of
techno signatures like avi and like
michio kaku
who have thought about aliens in great
detail and discussed that with me on my
podcast and i could put links and cards
and so forth later on
um but uh but you know they don't seem
to be advocating that these data
really are substantive for the existence
of
of alien presence or technology
what do you make of that should that be
dismissed or could that just be a case
of well they're not pilots so
we shouldn't trust them well there i
mean you've got to look at the evidence
the evidence really isn't indicative of
aliens people are seeing things that
you know they can't explain but that
doesn't mean that they're aliens you
know there's a multiple
multitude of possible explanations
running all the way from
uh people misperceiving things
uh to various types of natural phenomena
or things like foreign drones or even
and drones from like the kid down the
road that's flying up over your house
there's all kinds of explanations that
are generally a better fit
than the idea of aliens the aliens is a
an extraordinary
explanation for any particular uh given
case if you take like even the nimitz
encounter
which is presented as being one of the
best evidence of aliens out there but
the idea that there's no simpler
explanation than aliens
it's just it's quite ludicrous really
there's there's lots of explanations
even though they're perhaps you know a
bit unlikely some of them
yeah it is alien visitors actually a
more likely thing than these these other
explanations right i had this debate you
know being a little bit too provocative
perhaps but you know there's a there's a
notion in philosophy called abduction
and i joke about alien abduction so
abduction is the philosophical
reasoning tool of inference to the best
explanation and we use this as a
scientist
people in the chat room have been
pointing out that william of acham
you know i'm probably saying that too
much hebrew with the hat i shouldn't be
doing that
but uh william of occam you know said
that the simplest explanation is
probably the best
so my friend david brin who is a phd
astrophysicist
at uc san diego renowned science fiction
writer as well
sends you his regards uh he's not in the
chat room as far as i can tell
but he says you know tell mick he's
doing great uh work but he's saying also
something very important mick
he says mick um just remember you don't
have to account for everything you as a
debunker
you know it's sort of said about like
people that work on you know in
defense you they they have to be right
every time
uh but you don't have to be right every
time in other words you don't have to
account for everything
even david brin says even if there are
some actually physical blob effects in
the atmosphere that emit light
and swerve and veer in non-newtonian
waves there can be
alternative explanations within the laws
of physics as we know it the purported
behavior could be a
quote unquote the same as a cat laser
effect okay he's being shorthand but in
other words there could be effects like
if you say
if you take a cat laser and you sh and
you shine it towards proxima centauri
over there and then you turn it around
the opposite direction and shine it
towards the virgo
uh constellation over there they'll
actually receive these two bursts of
light
instantaneously you know each one will
receive it and then somehow they could
reason
oh well they saw at the same time there
must be faster than light travel no we
just used a cat laser
and there's no there's no need to
distinguish or to provide
extra extra einsteinian space time
violations
so in other words he's saying there's a
million ways he says to cause a physical
blob in the atmosphere to emit light and
this is a very
you know he's a phd theoretical
astrophysicist caltech
and ucsd trained to emit light and
swerve and veer in non-newtonian ways
he could do it david brin could do it
with a half a million dollars worth of
equipment which suggests that the
fellows responsible are
um quote human so he's basically making
this alien abduction
you know abduction meaning reasoning to
the simplest possible hypothesis which
is what i want my audience is so
brilliant
and i claim you know i've had nine nobel
prize winners on this audience
uh is the best and brightest and i'm
gonna you know beg your adult i'm sure
your audience is just as bright
but i've had nine nobel prize winners on
this uh on the show
more are coming and uh and we like to go
extremely deep and and the point is we
take things from a scientific
perspective
again nothing would get i already have
tenure you know which is why i can have
people
on the show uh you know that i've had on
uh and be controversial perhaps
uh but uh but the point is the uh
the the process that i like to engage in
is to stimulate curiosity it's kind of a
drug that's very powerful and very
addictive to me personally but also i
i would like nothing more than to me to
shortcut
and hack the scientific method and know
things about the future
right and when you wouldn't we all like
to know the physics of the future
we would and if aliens arrived you know
theoretically they could give it to us
and that is one of the great attractions
of this the et hypothesis and it's you
know ties into science fiction and
uh and popular portrayals of aliens as
they are the the bearers of gifts great
gifts for humanity and
they are going to basically ascend
humanity to the next level and that's
why people are so interested
in that but you know i think that
creates
the willingness to overlook a lot of
things and the willingness to go towards
one particular explanation
when there are other explanations which
are perhaps less palatable
and in some ways a little bit more
complicated because you could actually
you know think about uh them rather than
just being a simple
aliens uh that's that actually make a
lot more sense and would have made more
sense to to william a bockham
and i actually i don't i use a
a reasoning technique for figuring
things out which i call
orcamic ranking uh which is
taking all positive all possible
hypotheses
everything that has been suggested and
everything i can think of
and putting them into a list and then
ranking them
by which seems the most likely basically
it's a huge heuristic you know you you
see does this seem more likely than
others based on the evidence
uh if this was to go up the list a bit
what would need to happen for this to go
up the list so i have these lists of
things and so used to
start at the top like uh with optical
illusions or balloons or
another plane or atmospheric effects or
cgi or the guy made a mistake it was all
a dream or he was lying and
aliens did it or it's a glitch in the
matrix it's part of the simulation so
you have
all the hypotheses and you try to figure
out which one of them
is at the top but you don't just focus
on that one you keep thinking about the
other things on the list as well because
quite often you have one two or three
things
near the top and one of them isn't a
clear winner
but people like to pick a clear winner
and i think that's a mistake
is to just go with one hypothesis
so i would encourage people to try this
out make a list
make a list of your hypotheses and give
them a rough ranking you can give them a
percentage as to how likely you think it
is to correct and just
sort them into order and then as new
information arises
you take them and you change the order
and new ones might bubble to the top and
things might fall to the bottom but you
know
you always keep things open as
possibilities
so we're gonna wrap up in the next few
minutes we'll they go on one or two more
questions
uh we have one uh here that
is a question about whether or not there
have been any kind of multi-sensor
uap with a radar signature been verified
to go into the ocean
or has that only been claimed via navy
witnesses in other words has there been
multiple
sonar plus radar confirmation or has
that only been
via the eyewitness data
this is something that you know people
have claimed a few times that there's
this one yeah there's these five
observables of ufos that
uh people say are signatures of of ufos
being something other than human
technology and and one of them is
transmedium travel which is something
that flies in
more or less equal speed through the air
and through the water and possibly space
too
uh and people have claimed that this has
happened that people have claimed that
there's radar data and then there's
sonar data but
there's this there's no real good
examples of this if you ask people to
point them out there's not actually
anything where you have any kind of
continuous chain of evidence from
from the radar to to the sonar uh
there was a recent case where a video
was released of
a sphere descending towards the horizon
and then a
video of a radar screen was released
which shows some targets on the radar
appearing to disappear uh off off the
screen which they did disappear off the
screen like they're just
blinked out of existence and people have
kind of said that is
uh evidence that something was going
underwater but it could equally have
been
the object simply going out of the radar
scan volume because it was a surface
scanning radar not actually something
designed to
scan things up in the sky so you know
shorthand sir no not that i know of
great um so this has been so much fun uh
people are asking you know will you
debate
uh commander fravor i'm gonna try to
make that i'm gonna make that happen
if i can first i'm gonna try to have a
conversation not a debate
i agree with my past guests uh lord
martin reese the astronomer royal
most debate is pointless uh but we
should debate with love
we should use occam's razor every now
and then to get a close shave
uh but we should do so with comity and
sometimes a little comedy
uh throw in a little bit of levity
shouldn't always be so super serious
um and uh and i really have enjoyed this
i want to ask people again
uh please do subscribe to mick west's
channel
and follow him he is doing yeoman's work
i don't think you're getting
uh compensated you know we youtubers
don't make that much money for
uh views and likes and subscribes but
please do like
comment and subscribe because it does
tell the algorithm there
are algorithms of advanced artificial
intelligence that do
kind of control our lives at least as
youtubers so help us out if you can
so mick uh please uh please i wish you
great success i hope you'll come back
tomorrow i do have on seth sostak
uh whose book confessions of an alien
hunter is a wonderful book
from an astronomer who himself has
searched for aliens
who would love nothing better than
aliens to be real i'm going to get him
to
to comment on some of the work that
you've done and some of the work that
we are involved with um in in
microwave and radio astronomy and also
physics of the future
and uh and then later i do hope to have
on some of these wonderful
very heroic patriotic pilots i've been
in contact with
two of them and and hopefully i i will
be able to get at least one or maybe two
of the pilots who are up close and
personal on various occasions
i do think that they have been a lovely
um you know they've done incredible work
um and and i think they should be uh
they should be part of all the
all the conversation and i don't think
they have anything to gain either in
fact i think that they've they probably
suffered a lot too
for everything that they've done and
they should not because i think that
they
are heroes as i know you do too mick so
i want to thank you mick
um for everything you do i want to
recommend your book again and your
youtube channel so please everybody
stay tuned for more episodes of into the
impossible tomorrow with dr brian
keating
and for now signing off and i encourage
you all to keep
watching the skies and watching the two
youtube channels
good night everybody thank you so much
mick have a wonderful wonderful yeah
any sufficient advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic